je vous propose de plonger dans un monde
que philippe de villiers n'aime pas
beaucoup c'est celui de la
mondialisation des grandes marques
internationales qui se mobilisent ces
temps ci sur le sujet de l'antiracisme
samedi dernier c'était l'oréal qui
annonçait qu'elle allait enlever
certains mots de ces emballages de
produits cosmétiques hommes blancs
blanchissant ou claire et puis il ya eu
coca cola qui lui suspend ses publicités
pour un mois sur tous les réseaux
sociaux en visant spécifiquement
facebook puisque et considère que
ce réseau ne fait pas suffisamment pour
stopper les propos racistes et puis vous
savez sans doute que mars réfléchit à
faire évoluer sa marque uncle ben's avec
en particulier la présence de ce
personnage noir sur ces paquets de riz
je vous donne un dernier exemple parce
que celui là il n'est pas encore
forcément très connus c'est quoi qu'est
rod qui est une filiale de pepsico qui
promet de retirer d'ici la fin de
l'année
sa tante jemima alors peut-être que vous
la connaissez pas parce que c'est sur un
produit qui est surtout vendue aux états
unis c'est une femme noire qui ornait
depuis 130 ans son sirop d'érable
quand vous voyez ce genre d'initiative
juste madjer est ce que vous vous
réjouissez c'est c'est quoi sceller le
capitalisme qui fait preuve de vertus on
peut on peut se réjouir mais pas
longtemps
papa très longtemps c'est à dire que en
fait la volonté d un certain nombre de
marques de récupérer des thèmes
d'engagement de société qui surgissent
régulièrement dans l'actualité
cette volonté c'est une stratégie
marketing qui est qui est très courante
chez les anglo saxons qui est très
courante aux états unis et on pourrait
c'est d'ailleurs assez intéressant de
voir comment des grandes marques je
pense que si on veut éviter ça pose
problème et grandes marques comme nike
coca cola ou même chez les gars femme
qui est intéressant de voir comment au
fil du temps ces marques ont toujours
essayé de se raccrocher à l'actualité et
aux thèmes d'engagement de féminisme
contre l'homophobie contre le racisme
aujourd'hui mais en réalité ce sont
vraiment des ce sont vraiment des
stratégies marketing
moi je trouve que l'exemple plus le plus
significatif de cette volonté de
récupérer et de détourner finalement
d'une certaine manière et des termes
d'engagement c'est ce qui s'est passé là
quelques jours chez mercedes c'est à
dire que mercedes à un pilote vedette
enfin en formule 1 c'est lewis hamilton
lewis hamilton
c'est un sportif
qui est un descendant d'esclave de l'île
de la grenade et lewis hamilton je crois
sincèrement les profondément bouleversé
et but par la sphère georges floride par
l'assassinât et donc il veut faire
quelque chose il trouve il a envie de
réagir il a envie d'utiliser sa position
médiatique pour dire il faut que ça va
être le racisme ça n'est pas possible et
la mercedes l'écoutent il va voir son
directeur chez mercedes il lui dit il
faut qu'on fasse quelque chose
j'ai envie de s'exprimer je ne peux pas
réagir
hélas la proposition que lui fait
mercedes et de lui dire ok on va peindre
la voiture vedette formule 1 en noir on
va mettre sur la voiture
blake lively matters et on va mettre un
dock racisme sur la voiture c'est à dire
que ce qui est au départ une démarche
tout à fait honorable et vertueuse de la
part de lewis hamilton
ça devient ça devient une stratégie
commerciale pour faire parler de
mercedes sur les circuits de formule 1
et là là c'est un vrai problème parce
que du coup le risque évidemment c'est
que on risque de vider totalement dans
du contenu de ces engagements et on
risque de les banaliser dans des
produits de consommation qui ne veulent
absolument plus rien dire alors les
internautes sont assez sceptiques 1 /
sur ses initiatives
regardez cette réaction de ramia tagro
bis bis qui nous dit donc maintenant
c'est coca cola qui décide quels sont
les opinions acceptable ou non du tout
évident ça lui plaît pas beaucoup
et voici encore un témoignage celui de
sarko lite qui considère que cette
hystérie est totalement contreproductive
et que leur à moyen et long terme
les résultats exactement opposée au
dessin visé et puis
c'est de l'avis de la très grande
majorité de ceux qui s'expriment sur
youtube sur ce sujet est ce que les
marques en font trop pourtant en matière
d'initiatives antiraciste c'est oui à 80
oui à 88%
mais sur twitter il ya quand même des
opinions plus tempérée par exemple celle
de maïté ramos qui nous dit ça n'est pas
un problème que les marques s'engage ce
qu'il faut c'est qu'elle communique
mieux et qu'elle explique aux
consommateurs le peu le problème le
sujet et puis un dernier point de vue
solide brian sur youtube qui considère
que l'oréal
donc le real qui a supprimé les mentions
produits blancs ou éclaircissants sur
ces
produits cosmétiques c'est nul doute que
le real va augmenter ses recettes
financières avec sa politique anti
mention blanc sur ces produits
est-ce que c'est certain que ça judith
waintraub que ce soit une bonne idée
même en termes de marketing ses prises
de position il ya des gens que ça peut
énerver
il y avait d'ailleurs sur twitter des
appels à un boycott de l'oréal oui alors
tout de suite après l'action a un peu
baissé d'ailleurs l'action de l'oréal
lors elle qui n'en est pas à son coup
d'essai c'est pour ça que c'est très
étonnant que les continue en 2018
il avait choisi comme mannequin pour un
shampoing une femme voilée qui portait
son voile pour vous porter pour se
compter a introduit pour les chevaux
voilà un choix qui lui a parfois mais en
plus ils ont découvert que le mannequin
en question était l'auteur de tweet très
violemment anti-israélien voc évidemment
la campagne a été annulé c'est un jeu
extrêmement dangereux moi je trouve que
c'est tout simplement prendre les gens
pour des imbéciles que je ne connais pas
alors c'est surtout apparemment le
marché asiatique années les japonais les
chinois qui sont concernés qui achètent
ces produits dits éclaircissants ou
unifiant du tas je ne crois pas du tout
que les gens soient convaincus on en a
pas en tout cas de preuves du point de
vue commercial a plutôt la preuve du
contraire
et quant au fait que ça devienne
insupportable et au delà des campagnes
de boycott et de leur succès éventuel
je crois que oui et ça a été à mon avis
et c'est une des raisons pour lesquelles
malgré sa gestion pour le moins
hasardeuse de la crise dure coronavirus
donald trump commence à reprendre du
poil de la bête parce que les
manifestations
à la suite de l'assassinât de georges
floyd les violences et les dérives de
ces manifestations commencent à
ressouder son électorat
laurent alexandre quel est votre intime
conviction vous avez créé plusieurs
sociétés
vous accompagnez des start-up donc vous
connaissez intimement le monde de
l'entreprise
vous pensez qu elles sont sincères ces
sociétés quand elles font ça ou que
c'est juste commercialement efficace en
tout cas c'est ce qu'elle croit je pense
que les gens de l'oréal sont très
intelligents savent qu'ils vont perdre
quelques utilisateurs et quelques
acheteurs qui vont comme judith est
énervé par cette récup
mais l'essentiel pour l'oréal c'est pas
le marché français qui est secondaire si
l'on raisonne à la fin du siècle puisque
la population d'afrique noire
subsaharienne dépassera 4 milliard
d'habitants en 2100 c'est un marché qui
est 80 80 fois plus important que la
france donc
l'oréal veut donner des gages aux
racialiste et aux gens qui défendre la
plaie les populations afro américaines
ou africaines d'afrique ou pense pensent
le faire
c'est une stratégie marketing qui du
point de vue de l'oréal est probablement
gagnante mais même si quelques bourgeois
intellectuelle humaniste parisiens vont
être énervé mais comme je le suis c'est
à dire de remettre la race au coeur du
discours social au coeur du discours
politique en 2020 j'ai envie de gerber
c'est à dire que la stratégie d traoré
la stratégie des groupuscules racialiste
qui veulent de l'apartheid qui veulent
des réunions en aura 6 et où les blancs
n'ont pas le droit d'aller qui veulent
faire des réunions des gros des partis
par as ça me donne envie de gerber en
tant qu' en tant qu'humaniste ça
m'insupporte
on reste ici est promenée programme est
vraiment mon progressisme et
profondément affecté par ce retour de la
race et les gens comme le real qui joue
en réalité ce retour de la race en
faisant des autodafés de marque et des
autodafés de notice d'emploi
je trouve ne sont pas très courageux et
et ils vont plutôt dans le mauvais sens
par rapport à la vision humaniste que
que j'ai judith vous voulez réagir dans
jcs
moi je ne prends pas que les habitants
des pays d'afrique soient plus con que
le bourgeois blanc qui ne supporte pas
ces manoeuvres l'afrique et les pays
africains heureusement ne sont pas un
peuple est majoritairement de racialiste
c'est un phénomène absolument
enfin beaucoup plus de repères et
américains étasunien kaka phénomène
africain point de vue sur ce sujet mais
je suis d'accord avec laurent exemple je
crois que c'est la première fois je vous
avoue que que ça me fait tout drôle mais
déjà non gelée je ne m'attends pas
d'abord parce que les marques d'une
manière générale fasse preuve d'éthique
même quand elles l'affirment elles sont
en effet régi par parler mars kisling
par l'appât du gain
l'argent des courtisanes universel
aujourd'hui ils ont décidé de se saisir
des enjeux diversiterre jeudi
aujourd'hui ça me manque quand même à
quelques années on parle de l'oréal on
pourrait parler de netflix ou même de
hubert un über qui proposait une
réduction aux clients uber états unis
humeur amérique au client qui décide et
de consommer chez un restaurateur noir
donc ce qui peut paraître assez
paradoxal parce que toutes ces marques
participent aussi à l'exploitation des
minorités qu'elles prétendent défendre
c'est ces gens là qui participent à
cette révolution donc et qui vont
envoyer des signes pour être mieux
considérés dans l'espace public
le problème c'est que les marques
participent de plus en plus à nos
représentations du monde
il leur homme est vraiment vraiment
croissant et profond ce qui pose
problème puisque là il réactive ou
actives bell des débats les clivages des
clivages raciaux
c'est pam s'est pas seulement d'ailleurs
dans la représentation dans le marketing
au sein même justement des entreprises
on observe justement en cette perte de
liberté et cette idéologie voire même
des pressions totalitaire auprès des
employés une petite anecdote qui n'en
est pas une en fait un kaki simplement
le reflet d'un mouvement plus profond
c'est cette journaliste il ya quelques
jours cette journaliste canadienne
anglophone de la sib ici qui a reçu un
blâme qui a dû s'excuser publiquement
pour avoir prononcé dans le cadre d'une
réunion le titre d'un livre un livre
québécois de classe de pierre vallières
qui s'appelle [ __ ] blancs d'amérique
ça doit value donc en blane demande
excuses publiques etc
donc il ya un mouvement en effet très
profond auquel participe largement les
marques et qui en fait petit à petit
sein des sociétés est d'autant plus sa
société française qui est évidemment une
société nationale qui repose justement
sur sur la république
donc oui il ya ces espèces de censure au
nom de l'engagement et de l'empathie à
l'égard de minorité sur lesquels ses
marques s'asseyent volontiers on
pourrait ajouter quand même on pourrait
ajouter que là où il ya une certaine du
prix c'est que ces grandes marques qui
se met dans la vague anti raciste dans
la vague et doivent l'homme des libertés
il faudrait quand même qu'elle regarde
ce qu'elles font elles par exemple quand
on fait travailler des enfants en
turquie en indonésie en asie pour
produire pour produire des baskets à des
prix dérisoires
vous êtes qu' il faudrait quand même
commencer par se regarder soi même et
parce qu'aujourd'hui le problème de
l'esclavagé
il n'est pas justement dans ces pays
occidentaux qu'on pointe du doigt mais
en effet dans les pays que vous venez de
citer
absolument vous disiez vous avez plutôt
de la sympathie pour ses prises de
position même si vous ne le pensiez pas
forcément sincère mais est-ce que ce
retour de la race dans le discours
public et notamment le discours des
marques commerciales ne vous inquiète
pas alors oui et non oui et non c'est à
dire que moi je ressens quand même le
besoin
de modifier la représentation des
sociétés dans l'ensemble des univers les
marques c'est un univers la télévision
c'est un univers et je ressens quand
même le fait qu' on ne peut pas occulter
nier le fait qu'il ya toute une partie
de la société qui jusqu'à présent elle a
quand même été largement mises de côté
et on a absolument fait en sorte de ne
pas la représenter et d'ailleurs ça crée
des problèmes
c'est à dire qu'à un moment donné quand
il ya un trop grand décalage entre ce
que l'on mais est ce que l'on voit eh
bien on finit par ressentir de
l'amertume
on finit par se révolter ont fini par
forcer le monde tel qu'il nous est
montré n'est pas celui que l'on vit donc
ça c'est ça je dirais c'est nécessaire
de modifier sa mère même temps là où
vous avez raison c'est vrai
effectivement le risque c'est une dérive
communautariste à l'américaine ou à
l'entrée de certaines salles dans
certaines universités
si vous n'êtes pas si je te perds
religion vous ne pouvez pas entrer
si vous n'êtes pas de quelle couleur de
peau vous ne pouvez pas entrer
si vous n'êtes pas cg pas rien vous ne
pouvez pas andré etc etc
donc ça ça c'est une société absolument
insupportable et il faut donc il faut il
faut retrouver un équilibre entre une
une représentation de la société qu'ils
soient qu'ils soient réels et en même
temps lutte est absolument contre ces
dérives clanique et communaux perdition
juste un mot sur cette représentation de
la société réelle
vous avez de manière récurrente depuis
20 ans un débat sur les vêtements et
notamment les vêtements féminins les
mannequins qui les présente qui sont qui
font tout à mettre 80 qui sont filiforme
et qui évidemment ne colle pas à la
moyenne des deux la clientèle féminine
qui pourrait les acheter ça n'a jamais
fonctionné
on n'a jamais réussi entre temps il ya
une marque qui se distingue en disant
voilà nous on présente des vraies femmes
qui portent le produit qui s'en félicite
et qui sont épanouissent ça ne marche
pas la cub ci par la réalité
ces deux choses différentes
merci beaucoup merci à tous les cartes
je vais laisser le dernier mot aux
internautes encore de réaction pour
finir plus tôt plutôt critique un là
encore sur ses initiatives celle
d'anthony montana sur youtube qui
qualifie les réactions des marques de
clientélisme cynique
rien que ça et puis kris kross qui pense
qu'en fait ça va être contre-productif
commercialement c'est initiative et on
verra ça d'ici quelques mois merci
beaucoup à tous les quatre merci à vous
tous qui nous avaient suivis et à demain
pour un nouveau rendez vous d'un point
de vue bonne soirée
[Musique]